Olá pessoal que prazer estar aqui com
vocês novamente para mais um vídeo aqui
no nosso canal hipotálamo é uma glândula
bastante esquecida ou desconhecida para
a maioria das pessoas mas ela pode ser
considerado o centro de comando paraa
maioria dos hormônios integrando o
sistema nervoso ao sistema endócrino e
desempenha assim um papel essencial na
manutenção do nosso equilíbrio interno
do corpo então é um órgão fundamental
paraa nossa saúde o hipotálamo produz
hormônios que controla a temperatura
corporal a frequência cardíaca a pressão
arterial o crescimento a fome o humor o
desejo sexual o sono é até a sede
hormônios como a dopamina oxitocina e
hormônio liberador de tirotropina São
alguns exemplos de composto produzidos
pelo hipotálamo com funções vitais no
nosso corpo então onde que ela está esta
glândula tá situada no cérebro logo
acima da base do crânio é um órgão
pequeno no tamanho de uma amêndoa
coordena atividade do sistema nervoso
autônomo e também desempenha um papel
significativo na função do sistema
endócrino devido a sua complexa relação
com a glândula pituitária ou hipófise
quando o hipotálamo não funciona de
forma adequada isso prejudica o
funcionamento da glândula hipófise ou
pituitária que controla as adrenais os
ovários os testículos e a tireoide então
é muito importante essa correlação entre
hipotálamo hipófise o objetivo do
hipotálamo é responder as informações
sensoriais e fazer fazer ajuste em todo
o corpo adaptando o que está acontecendo
com objetivo de criar equilíbrio ou
homeostase então hipotálamo é
fundamental pra saúde da tireoide
influencia a produção dos hormônios T4 e
T3 pela detecção de suas necessidades e
comunica-se com a glândula hipófise Opá
Então essa interação regula a liberação
do TSH que é o hormônio estimulante da
tireoide isso vai ajustar os níveis dos
hormônios tiroidianos no entanto
distúrbios como o hipotiroidismo ou
Doença de rachim noto podem prejudicar
essa dinâmica afetando a função do TSH e
consequentemente a regulação hormonal
tiroidiana então a hipófise hipotálamo
podde ser também causas de
hipotiroidismo ou serem afetados pelo
próprio hipotiroidismo o que afeta então
a função do hipotálamo pode ser cirurgia
trauma batida na cabeça obesidade
radiação toxinas e tumores são as causas
mais comuns de mal funcionamento do
hipotálamo então o baixo funcionamento
adrenal ou insuficiência adrenal está
associado ao mau funcionamento do
hipotálamo existem também várias outras
possíveis causas de um distúrbio do
hipotálamo incluindo desnutrição
infecções
inflamação sangramento transtornos
alimentares como anorexia e bulimia e
distúrbios genéticos que causam acúmulo
de ferro no corpo Então quais são os
problemas de saúde que são associadas à
disfunção do hipotálamo São tumores
cerebrais hipotiroidismo e doença de
rachim
hipopituitarismo que é o deficiência de
funcionamento da hipófise é uma condição
Rara felizmente né que essa glândula não
consegue produzir um ou mais hormônios
deficiência de hormônio de crescimento
hipogonadismo masculino secundá que é
uma condição na qual uma produção
insuficiente de testosterona ocorre
devido a um problema do hipotálamo ou da
pituitária Então quais são as
estratégias naturais pra gente poder
fortalecer o nosso hipotálamo e não ter
todos esses problemas manter uma rotina
de exercícios moderados um estudo
demonstrou que o exercício contínuo tem
um efeito positivo tanto na expressão
genética quanto na atividade neuronal do
hipotálamo contribuindo para a regulação
da pressão arterial em animais
hipertensos outra medida muito
importante é consumir gorduras saudáveis
gorduras insaturadas e saturadas de boa
qualidade são fundamentais paraa
produção hormonal e para a saúde do
cérebro com fontes recomendadas
incluindo o azeite de oliva óleo de coco
abacate salmão e sardinha ou suplementos
de ômega-3 também consuma polifenois os
polifenois são compostos presentes numa
variedade de alimentos e bebidas como
frutas vermelhas chá vinho tinto e
muitos vegetais verdes segundo as
pesquisas os polifenóis podem ajudar a
reduzir a inflamação do hipotálamo o que
pode ajudar a prevenir disfunções outra
medida muito importante evitar os
carboidratos refinados e açúcares o
excesso de carboidratos refinados pode
causar inflamação no hipot Hi tálamo
levar a síndrome metabólica visto que
pesquisas mostraram que pessoas obesas
têm um maior problema de funcionamento
do hipotálamo também aumentar a ingestão
de cromo a ingestão de cromo está
associado à manutenção de um hipotalamo
mais jovem e a regulação da Peti osos
sendo alimentos como brócolis batatas e
carne bovina alimentada com capim são
boas Fontes desse mineral a vitamina B1
an tiamina também é uma boa ideia junto
com a B12 a metilcobalamina São ess iis
paraa saúde do hipotálamo a tiamina
ajuda a regular ou gerenciar o centro de
sociedade no hipotálamo influenciando
diretamente apetite funcionamento do
sistema nervoso que está ligado de forma
direta ao sistema endócrino através do
hipotálamo e da glândula pitá por outro
lado a B12 está ligado à melhoria dos
níveis de energia redução de fadiga
diminuição dos sintomas de depressão e
ao suporte adequado do sistema nervoso
central reforçando a importância dessas
vitaminas para funcion ento otimizado
hipotálamo outra medida bem interessante
usa óleos essenciais seja de olíbano que
é um Frank sense e o de mirra esses
óleos têm propriedades antiinflamatórias
antioxidantes com compostos ativos como
sesquiterpenos que aumenta o oxigênio ao
redor dos receptores próximos ao
hipotálamo as glândulas pineal e
pituitária mantendo saudável Então os
squirter penos também afetam
especificamente o nosso centro emocional
do hipotálamo ajudando a gente a
permanecer calmos e equilibrados também
Experimente o fitoterápico vitex que é o
vitex Agnus castos especialmente
benéfico para as mulheres ele vai atuar
indiretamente no equilíbrio hormonal ao
influenciar o hipotálamo e a glândula I
pituitária sendo útil para condições
como síndrome do ovalo policístico e
infertilidade a meditação que tanta
gente não quer fazer ela é muito
importante ela pode melhorar a função do
hipotálamo reduzindo o estresse
diminuindo a liberação de cortisol que é
o hormônio do estresse que afeta de
forma negativa hipotálamo em excesso
além disso a meditação pode aumentar a
atividade neuronal em áreas do cérebro
associadas ao bem-estar e a
tranquilidade dando suporte à saúde
geral do hipotálamo também priorizar o
sono de qualidade gerenciamento do
estresse o sono adequado e a redução do
estresse são essenciais para regular os
níveis de cortisol e manter a função do
hipotálamo otimizada como o cortisol é
regulado pelo eixo hipotálamo hipófise
adrenal e o cortisol é o principal
hormônio responsável pela resposta ao
estresse manter a produção de cortisol
Em um nível saudável por meio de sono
adequado e redução do estresse é muito
útil paraa saúde do hipotálamo bem como
das glândulas associadas pituitária e
adrenal um grande abraço e um beijo no
seu coração Você é fera